[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
bien
pour ma part je suis vraiment très
heureuse d'être d'être parmi vous cet
après midi donc pour commencer j'ai
décidé de l'introduire un peu mon
terrain de jeu avec deux chiffres donc
forcément j'aurais préféré 20 et 24 pour
paris 2024 ça faisait un peu écho à
l'actualité mais malheureusement fallu
que je commence en vous mettant alors 22
c'est tout simplement le nombre d'années
depuis lequel je pratique l'athlétisme
voilà c'est mon sport c'est ma passion
et 24,6 simplement le nombre de
médailles que j'ai gagné à
l'international jeux paralympiques
championnat du monde et championnat
d'heure donc voilà donc merci j'ai un
timing à tenir donc on va éviter trop
les applaudissements un bien sûr non je
rigole bien sûr merci beaucoup ça ça me
ça me touche donc voilà donc deux
chiffres qui résument à un parcours donc
un parcours à la fois long et qui pour
ma part me semble réussi mais pour être
honnête avec vous à la base ce terrain
de jeu 7 cet amusement gelé découvert
par accident
au sens propre et au sens figuré parce
que comme le disait gentiment nicolas
tout à l'heure bah moi mon rêve quand
j'étais petite idée devenir
sapeur-pompier professionnel
voilà c'était le terrain de jeu sur
lequel je voulais m'amuser c'était mon
ambition ma passion et le et le métier
que je voulais occupée malheureusement
en 2004 à l'âge de 15 ans j'ai été
renversée par une voiture est amputé
d'une jambe
donc forcément avec une jambe en moins
c'est on peut faire du lasergame on l'a
compris tout à l'heure mais être pompier
c'est pas possible
donc voilà on se dit pas c'est un drame
la vie s'arrête tout s'arrête
mais non voilà c'est pas avec un
accident de la vie c'est pas parce qu'on
a une jambe en moins que tout s'arrête
et sa part la présence de mes proches de
mon entourage de plein d'autres choses
dans la vie je les très vite compris et
ce que j'ai compris en fait c'était que
ce changement
cette difficulté ce
cette erreur de parcours que je
rencontre et si je vais envoyer comme
quelque chose de positif si j'arrivais à
en saisir les opportunités et bâle
chargé à moi de rendre la vie plus belle
alors je savais pas ce que serait ma vie
je savais qu'elle serait différente et
je savais qu'il fallait que j'aille sur
un nouveau terrain de jeu et ce terrain
de jeu bah ils étaient déjà écrits
depuis quelques années c'était
l'athlétisme et cette année par enfin
dans les prochaines années j'avais
simplement à le faire maintenant
en handisport donc au début à la reprise
de cet accident j'en ai fait en loisirs
et petit à petit j'ai décidé de
construire une carrière d'athlète de
haut niveau donc voilà pour le cadre un
peu de mon terrain de jeu vouloir faire
du sport de haut niveau vouloir être à
la tête de haut niveau faire reposer son
ambition et sa réussite de vie autour du
sport de haut niveau est quelque chose
de compliqué parce que le sport de haut
niveau c'est un terrain de jeu qui est
toujours en évolution où le niveau qui
est requis pour être le meilleur au
monde le meilleur des jeux est toujours
en augmentation et vous avez beau mettre
de la charge de travail supplémentaire
elle beaucoup plus performant dans votre
préparation vous ne savez même pas si
cela servira à vous maintenir à votre
niveau
donc c'est forcément un risque et
beaucoup de difficultés qui sont qui
sont face à vous pour autant c'est aussi
grisant parce que grâce au sport de haut
niveau par ce besoin continuel d'être
meilleur chaque année vous allez
développer des nouvelles compétences et
vous allez apprendre à vous connaître et
ça c'est exceptionnel et au cours des
trois olympiades que j'ai l'occasion de
faire des trois paralympiens j'ai fait
beaucoup d'apprentissage et je vais j'ai
décidé aujourd'hui de vous en présenter
3 et les relier aux au jeu que j'ai pu
faire
le premier apprentissage qui est liée
plutôt malheureusement un échec et que
en participant aux jeux paralympiques
on vit l'expérience des jeux
paralympiques sa grandeur sa magie sa
décadence et malheureusement cette magie
des jeux si vous n'êtes pas focalisé sur
votre objectif
si vous ne savez pas pourquoi vous êtes
présent cette magie à vavoua paix et
vous sortir totalement de votre terrain
de jeu moi je suis arrivé aux jeux
paralympiques de 2008 j'avais à peine 20
ans à l'époque c'étaient mes premiers
jeux
je voulais et je pouvais être médaillée
d'or sauf que j'arrive dans ce village
arrivée en chine premier grand
déplacement comme ça dans dans un pays
très loin de chez moi
et là je suis appelé par happé par la
magie je me déplace beaucoup dans le
village je vais faire du shopping
je vais un petit peu visité la vie les
choses comme ça et j'en oublie
totalement mon objectif est
malheureusement ça m'a coûté le titre
paralympique en 2008
mais par chance j'ai quand même été
médaillés c'est donc forte de cette
expérience de me dire ok tu dois être
sur ton terrain de jeu tu dois
m'imprégner de cette magie du ton
terrain de jeu mais tu dois pas en
oublier ton objectif que je suis reparti
sur sur londres en 2012
donc je suis reparti sur sur londres en
2012 en m'améliorant en m'améliorant
donc sur ma focalisation attentionnel de
l'objectif mais aussi en améliorant tout
le travail que je pouvais faire c'est à
dire j'ai décidé en 2009 de devenir une
vraie athlètes de haut niveau et de tout
mettre en oeuvre dans ma vie pour
réussir dans le sport
donc tous les sacrifices de vie qui sont
nécessaires tout l'hygiène alimentaire
qui est nécessaire et toute la charge
d'entraînement nécessaire et cet
entraînement toutes ces heures qui
contraignait mon planning ma vie celle
de mon entourage et de mes conjoint je
le voyais pas comme une charge
parce qu'en fait quand je vais arriver
aux compétitions de haut niveau quand
j'arrivais en équipe de france
j'avais un tel bonheur de telles
émotions que je comprenais pourquoi
j'avais trop j'avais travaillé et je me
suis rendu compte que plus je
travaillais pour gagner plus était
difficile de gagner et plus la victoire
elle était belle et en fait c'était
vraiment dans les moments où il y avait
le plus d'adversité où je gagnais de la
plus faible des marches que j'avais
énormément d'émotion et c'est ce qui
rend le titre paralympique que j'ai pu
gagner en 2012 aussi beau c'est qu'en
fait je cours je prends le départ je
suis largement en tête et plus la course
avance et plus mes adversaires
reviennent alors moi je les vois pas
mais je les sens je les sens dans mon
dos je les sens me doubler et la ligne
franchie je chute
et là je suis assise voilà c'est la
faute aux convois je suis assise par
terre je regarde le panneau
et je me dis oh là là on a travaillé
pendant des années pour pour rien parce
que deuxième c'était pas mon objectif
donc va on a travaillé pendant toutes
ces années pour pour rien donc falloir
repartir et la joue en 5 secondes
je commence déjà à refaire tout le plan
d'entraînement des quatre prochaines
années à venir pour revit cette émotion
et cet intérêt certitude de la victoire
le fait de pas savoir pendant ces trente
secondes que j'avais gagné et ben
finalement quand c'est mon nom qui
s'affiche sur le panneau d'affichage et
que je sais que je suis enfin championne
paralympique et bat l'émotion elle est
immense
elle est extraordinaire et elle est
proportionnelle à toutes les années de
sacrifices qu'on a pu faire avant est
tellement enthousiaste de cette victoire
forcément je me dis allez on part on va
en dont on va pour les jeux de 2016 on
repart tout de suite pour les chanteurs
bonne que la du monde en 2013
donc je repars sur les championnats du
monde avec la volonté forcément d'être
championne du monde et de réussir les
jeux paralympiques de 2016 et la grosse
erreur grosse erreur je me perds
totalement je me perds totalement parce
que je suis focalisé sur je veux être
championne paralympique
je veux être championne du monde et pas
pourquoi je veux l'être est en fait en
étant focalisées simplement sur le ce
que je veux faire en étant sur le
comment je dois le faire eh ben j'ai
perdu tout le plaisir de mon sport j'ai
perdu le plaisir du travail et
finalement préparer les championnats du
monde en 2013 était devenu vraiment une
charge quelque chose que je subissais et
je prenais plus de plaisir sauf qu'on la
dit juste avant dans la notion de jeu et
moi proment les jeux paralympiques le
sport de haut niveau reste un jeu je ne
prenais plus de plaisir est là j'étais
en dissonance
je décide donc en 2014 de m'éloigner des
stades et de retrouver le plaisir du
travail le plaisir de l'entraînement
et encore une fois c'est fort vraiment
de fortes de ces de ses apprentissages
que j'ai continué ma préparation pour
les jeux de rio en 2016
hélas ces jeux de rio ils ont été
extraordinaires
magnifique parce que grâce à mon
préparateur mental j'aimerais bien vous
dire que cet apprentissage les faits
tout seul mais il ya eu un long chemin
de pour comprendre grâce à mon
préparateur mental j'ai été en capacité
de prendre du plaisir même si j'avais
une pression monstre parce que quand
vous êtes championne paralympique en
2012 on attend forcément de vous que
vous soyez aussi fort quatre ans plus
tard voire plus forts etc
malgré cette pression une préparation
qui a été très compliqué avec de
nombreuses blessures sur la fin que je
suis arrivée à rio et que j'ai pris
énormément de plaisir
deux solutions très simples pour prendre
le temps de plaisir la première ne pas
chercher à gagner un peu particulier j'y
vais pour être championne paralympique
pour autant quand je prends le départ du
concours de longueur et du 400 m il faut
pas que ce soit focalisé sur le fait de
gagner
non faut que je sois focaliser sur le
plaisir du geste sur la passion de mon
sport la passion de mon jeu et c'est des
choses très simples c'est à dire que
quand je cours quand je m'élance sur ma
course d'élan
je pense pas aux résultats je pense pas
au fait qu'il faut que je me fasse
quasiment six mètres pour gagner
non je pense aux pieds qui est fort au
sol au plaisir que ça me procure à
l'impulsion et le fait d'être en l'air
voilà je veux chercher à être vraiment
sûr ce plaisir de réalisation qui
m'anime depuis plus de vingt ans
maintenant si je fais de la clé c'est
parce que j'y trouve du plaisir et donc
je suis vraiment focalisé sur ça et pas
sur le fait de vouloir faire le saut
parfait le jour j c'était vraiment ça
mon problème en fait c'était pour gagner
j'avais l'impression que le jour j il
fallait faire le geste parfait alors que
non c'est pas du tout ce qu'on me
demande est ce qu'on me demandait pour
être médaillés d'or c'est d'appliquer ce
que j'avais appris pendant des années
d'entraînement et surtout pas de
chercher le jour j à faire mieux voilà
et en ne cherchant pas à faire mieux en
faisant simplement ce que je sais faire
et ce que j'ai travaillé pendant des
années et ben finalement j'ai atteint
des niveaux de performance assez
exceptionnel et une autre chose qu'on
avait détecté et qui finalement briser
totalement mon plaisir du jeu à très
haut niveau c'est que quand je me
concentrer pour pour faire une grande
compétition quand je me concentrais pour
partir en finale des jeux j'étais
hermétique hermétique aux partages
hermétique aux gens qui m'entouraient et
cette bulle de concentration finalement
où j'étais tout seul où j'étais
concentré sur l'action à faire sur le
résultat à obtenir faisait
je ne rentrais pas en interaction avec
les coaches avec ma famille avec le
public avec mes adversaires et je pense
que cette bulle de concentration
totalement hermétique faisait que
j'avais du mal à gérer la pression et
donc pendant les deux dernières années
de mon travail pour préparer les jeux de
rio 2016 avec mon coach mental on s'est
attelé justement à faire des petits
trous dans cette bulle de concentration
petit à petit on la percée on a laissé
les coaches rentrer dans cette bulle de
concentration on a laissé la famille
rentrait dans cette bulle de
concentration le public puis adversaire
est en fait le fait d'interagir le fait
quand à rio jus rentrent sur le stade et
que je souris au public que le public me
sourit en réponse que je demande la
clape au public et que le public un clap
tout au long de la course d'élan le fait
que je rigole avec mamie coach ma
famille le fait que je rigole avec mes
adversaires fait que je n'ai eu aucune
pression pendant le concours de longueur
parce qu'en fait mon attention elles
étaient focalisés sur autre chose a été
focalisé sur le plaisir du partage le
plaisir de l'interaction et non pas sur
la volonté absolument de réussir donc
j'ai été en extrême réussit à rio et
j'ai pris dix fois plus de plaisir que
lors des jeux de londres
donc voilà donc c'est ça vraiment le
secret de mon jeu c'est d'arriver en
fait à se délocaliser du résultat à
prendre en compte l'environnement a
partagé avec lui parce que je vous
assure que dans un jeu comme les jeux
paralympiques comme les jeux olympiques
comme le sport de haut niveau toutes
énergies qui est autour de vous et bonne
à prendre et celle du public
autant vous dire qu'à rio elle était
très forte elle était très fervente il
fallait savoir s'en nourrir et donc ça
doit vraiment été une une expérience ac
serait extraordinaire pour moi donc
voilà au travers de tout ce petit talk
au travers des différents apprentissages
que j'ai pu faire comme je vous le
disais le fait d'être en capacité est
assez ouvert pour saisir les
opportunités du changement sur le fait
de ne pas oublier que vous avez un
objectif autour de la magie de votre jeu
autour de tout ça des cadences sur le
fait d'être vraiment concentré sur le
plaisir en délocalisant de la volonté de
réussir et en étant vraiment dans le
partage dans les relations humaines
finalement
ces clés je pense qu'elles sont
transposables à l'ensemble de nos
terrains de jeu et qu'elles peuvent tous
nous permettre d'être performant au
quotidien dans notre travail et dans le
jeu voilà merci à tous
[Musique]